it's a pleasure to have peter
today from the institute of mathematics
and foods
and he'll tell us about quasi-ice melted
rigidity of the classic convex coke
introduction so i'm
very happy to be here and i would like
to thank the organizers for the
invitation i have to admit that when i
was a phd student i
most of the time i spent in the library
trying to make photocopies of the papers
of alforce and pearce
so
of course
my department was not very happy because
it cost a lot
okay so
the talk
i want to give will concern
contests to compact learning groups
let me remind you that
glendon group
is just a discrete
subgroup g
of p cell to c
and you can see it as acting
on hyperbolic 3-space properly
by isometries
and also you can see it as a conformal
dynamical system acting on the riemann
sphere by modulus transformations
okay so when you look at the action on
the
on the remains here
it is not always properly discontinuous
actually it's never
most of the time it's not but you have a
splitting of the
of the sphere into two
disjoint sets so one which is the limit
set
which
can be defined as the set of
accumulation points of one orbit
and the other is the set of
discontinuity
and so
as pancari had noticed you can see
the hyperlink 3 space as the open unit
ball in r3
and the remains here is can be seen as
the
as the boundary of the three ball
okay
and so then you get an action of your
group on the closed ball
right
and so
in this case
you see the limit set at infinity
maybe take color since
you have the chance to have some
so usually it's a fractal set which can
be very complicated okay and then
since the limit set is invariant by the
action of the group it's also the case
for
its
convex curve right
which i'm drawing roughly like this
and so then the group g
is convex compact
if
the action on the complex hole is
it's called complete so this is compact
right
and so
this class of groups
is very important and i would like to
give you two motivations to study such
groups and why they are
at least from my point of view
interesting
so first as explained jeremy can
yesterday it's tightly related to the
topology of three manifolds
so since the action is appropriate
discontinues
on h3 and also on the
set of discontinuity
what you can look at is that the orbit
space
of h3
and omega g over g and then you get an
ob fold okay so called container before
and when the group is torsion free then
you get
a manifold okay so in this setting
g will be convex for compact so i will
write c2k for convex compact
planing group
so g
is convex compact if and only if
mg is compact
and so it follows from the work of
thoughtstone and of pearlman that we
have a complete characterization of
those groups which
appear or those manifolds which can be
described as a quotient of the kenyan
group right so
the theorem
so first one is for the hacking case and
parallel manner for the general one
so i assume that you have
m3 is a
irreducible
orientable
compact
3-manifold
that it's a fundamental group
is infinite
and that you have no
z-square embedded into
the fundamental group
then you can find a
convex compartment in group g such that
m is homomorphic
range
and another interesting fact
a property of cleaning groups is the way
it acts
on its limit set when it's
contextual compact so this is called the
notion of a uniform convergence action
so you have a group acting by isometric
by homeomorphism on a compact set
and you say that the action is a unif uh
is a uniform convergence action
if
the action
on the set of distinct triples
is properly discontinuous
and go compact
okay so
it is a fact that
g
a canyon group
g is contextual compact
if and only if
the action is right
it's action
lambda g is a uniform convergence
and so you see we have two different
settings in which
these groups arise and
the
basic question is to say
how can we characterize such groups
in general
i don't know how
so in the talk this morning of casa rafi
he explained to us that when you have a
group which is finally generated then
you can see it as a geometric object
and from the geometric point of view
what you obtain
is that this geometry is not well
defined it's defined up to quasi
isometry okay so maybe i should recall
that is a quickly acquisition tree
so the quasi isometry
will be a map
file between two metric spaces
such that you have two constants lambda
and c
with the foreign property for each time
you pick two points
vx and gy
you look at its distance then it is
bounded by lambda d
distance from x to y up to an additive
constant
it is at least one over lambda
minus c and the other condition you want
is that the image of x to y is almost
subjective meaning that
for any y in the image
the distance from y to phi
is bounded by c
and so
from the point of view of geometric
group theory each time you prove a
property usually it's defined up to
quasi isometry
so if you want to characterize canon
groups then you get properties which
will be true for cleaning groups but
also for all the groups which are quasi
isometric to that group or to this class
of groups
and so it is a natural question to try
to understand
how big is the quasi-isometric class of
a context or compiling group
how can we single out this this
and so it turns out so i don't know if i
can erase this now
otherwise i can read down here also
but it turns out that actually the this
class is as small as possible
and so this is the
the main result of the stock
so ethereum is defined
so
if g
is
quasi isometric
to
a convex compact planing group k
then g contains
a finite index group
which
is
isomorphic
to a convex
compact tenon
and so there were of course prior to
this
general statement there were several
cases which were already known
that i should
state
so when the limit set of
k
is a circle then this is due to
casanova rice
and gabay
okay
when
landaka is the whole sphere
then this is due to cannon and cooper
and more recently
when
mdk is a serpent carpet
this followers from work are
bonk miranda
album
and there are also some easy cases which
can be ruled out
okay so maybe uh before i erase this i
forgot to comment on this definition
where the
a set of decent triples comes from and
why we have this property maybe
for a shame you pick three points
in the limit set
or at infinity and the remains here
can all it always defines an ideal
triangle right
and because you're in hyperbolic
geometry
you have a smallest
largest disk which will be tangent to
the three sides
okay so each time you look at the action
of three distinct points as if you were
looking at the action of the point in
the middle right
and so the action is properly
discontinuous on the set of triples just
means that it is properly discontinuous
in h3
saying that it is called compact it
means that it is congruent
right
so it's a natural way of trying to
translate
the notion of
convex compactness without hyperbolic
geometry
just by a dynamical point of view
okay
okay
so what i wanted to say is that there
are several cases that we could
okay so some easy cases where we can
understand
so first if if the limit set is is empty
then this means that k is finite
okay
and this implies that g will be finite
as well and so in this case you can just
take the neutral element it will be
through your it will be a finite index
subgroup which will act on hyperbolic
three space concepts
okay
so g contains the trivial element
not that's interesting but at least
whole semesters when lambda k has two
elements
then in this case you know that g has to
be virtually cyclic
and the same you can take any loxogenic
element that you want and it will
solve it
and there is a harder case is when
lambda k is a canter set
so it follows from work of
the woody i guess in selling so that
ge is virtually free
and here too you have many examples of
convex compact cleaning groups which are
free
okay so from now on i want to focus on
the cases when lambda k is connected
is connected
so of course it's not exactly the
complement set but still
okay
so i should maybe try to explain how do
we
translate the information of being quasi
isometric to a
convex or compact tenant group
how the assumption is used in this case
um
so the general theory tells you actually
that g will be word hyperbolic and then
it will its boundary will be homomorphic
to the limit set of k but in other words
what's important for us is that
g will act
on lambda k
as a uniform
convergence group
and
the action will also be uniformly quiz
images
okay so then
of being quasi isometric to
convex a compact line and group
so what you get is not only the fact
that the group is very hyperbolic but
you have the same conformal structure at
infinity
and this means that this action
is as you know
mobius maps preserve
cross ratio so here
we won't we are not looking at the
standard construction on the remains
here but at a metric cross ratio
which is essentially the same by taking
distances instead of
of differences so i look if i take two
four points a b c d i look at the
distance from a to b times the distance
from c to d
divided by the distance from a to c
times the distance from b
to d
and so an obvious map
will preserve across ratios
here we want something we have something
which is slightly weaker but still
uniform
so the thing that we have
a homomorphism distortion function
okay such that
so this is a homeomorphism
so that each time you pick four points
a b c d in the limit set of k each time
you pick an element g
in your group and you see how it acts on
this thing then the image the course
ratio
of the image of your far points
is controlled
by the cost ratio of your four points
okay
and so just note that if i exchange the
rule of b and c
what i do is i have the inverse cost
ratio so this is actually a double
inequality
so have control of the cross ratios on
both sides
this is some sort of
bounded distortion
for the dynamics
okay and so then you can think that
we're almost done because there is a
theorem concerning uniform actions of
quasi-mobius maps on the riemann sphere
right that i would like to recall right
now
so that if
g is a countable group
acting
on the riemann sphere by uniform
quiz images maps
then
g is present obviously conjugate to a
subgroup
m of the mobius
so it is conjugate to a group of mobius
transformation
okay
so see i guess you cannot read that no
because of the screen themselves
so
this means that in the case
of canon and cooper if the limit set is
the whole sphere then you get a global
action and you can apply the theorem to
get a convex compact landing
okay actually it will be compact in this
case so it's already done
but of course usually you don't have
such an action
the limit set is a one-dimensional
subset
so let me mention
also for the case of a circle
there's a theorem of
in canon and markovic
so he can improve one case and markerage
the
the missing cases
so if
in the case that
lambda k is a unit circle
then you have the same conclusion as in
sullivan's theorem namely that
the action of s1
is
so g
s1 is causing obviously conjugate to the
action of the legus
labius group
and so also this in this case it's a way
of settling and so here we get more
information actually than
the fact that you have a convergence
group and it is conjugated
and i will need this later
and so in the case also
the serpensky carpet
so if you know that
lambda k is a round carpet meaning that
the complement of the
or your compact set is around disks
then what
bonk liner and meringue prove is that
actually the group is already a subgroup
of the mobius transformation
of the remains here automatically so
then there's nothing to do okay
and so this
is equivalent to saying that k will be
the fundamental group of a hyperbolic
manifold with a geodesic boundary so
even if to start with the carpet is not
round you can always deform it to get it
with a
search property
okay so now
what i would like to try to explain is
how can we deal with the other cases
so first i would like to so here it's a
very nice
theorem but
it's a little cheating because
nothing needed to be done the group was
already a group of mobius
transformations i would like to explain
how we can make a different approach
for this case
and so
the assumption that i want to use and it
will be it will enable me to
generalize the ethereum to a broader
setting is the fact that the action is
assumed
to have what i want to call a planner
action
meaning
a purely or your group is just acting on
a compact set or a one-dimensional
compact set so you don't know exactly
how it how even to extend the dynamics
to the whole sphere it's not even clear
that there are restrictions of
homeomorphism of the whole stream
but in the case of carpets
it's always always the case because
since the the boundary components are
not separating the image is also a
non-separating jordan curve then it has
to to map
connected components of the complement
to connected component of the complement
so that's the assumption i would like to
make so
for any
omega connected component of the
complement
of the limit set
for any element of the group g
there is another connected component
of the complement
such that the boundary
of omega is mapped to the bar
so this means that i have an action on k
on the limit set of k and also an action
on the connected components of the
properly discontinuous set
and under this assumption
so it's a
basic set
what we can prove is that
the group g
the action of g
this conjugate
to
the action
of the
convex or compact learning group
okay so there are several ingredients so
the basic idea
is how can we
extend the dynamics
and this is where the work of
in canon and markovic
gets into the picture
because
for instance i will just look
i just want to give a brief idea
it's not even a sketch it's some sort of
hint where this should hold
so you have your component omega
so what you want to prove is that you
can map it
to the unit circle
and then you'll have an action on the
unit circle if you just look at the
stabilizer for instance
of this component
and then you know that
here you will get a because you
conjugate this
if you can do it by a question obvious
map then you get a uniformly
questionable section on the unit circle
so then by the theorem of in canon and
markovic
you know that it takes it is conjugate
to a
mobius group so it has an
extension to the whole disk
so then you don't have any chance of how
defining this extension
and this means that here you have a
natural extension to the
of the stabilizer to the whole thing and
this is the basic idea of how why it can
be worked like that so there are several
assumptions to check
first that this is a crazy disk but this
is true because i'm starting with a
convexor compact linen group
so the
the set of components
of the limit set of k
are uniform cozy discs
and in this setting
of a group acting uniformly
uniform quasimodo section
with a uniform convergence
i mean
you start with a group which are acting
uniformly
by uniform question obvious maps and
also which is a uniform convergence
group
in this case you also have a version of
the air force and that is
meaning that
you have
infinitely many of it
of the set of discontinuity
and the stabile stabilizers of any
connected component
is a
to a compact option group
so working a little more
what you can do is
extend the dynamics inside all the omega
limit set to have something which will
be uniformly causing abuse
on the
omega limit set and also
on the limit set
but then you have to check that you glue
when you glue both maps there remain
also crazy mobius right to be able to
apply the cylinder
and this is true
it can
way of doing that is using uh gearing's
definition of quasi-conformal mappings
saying that you look at very small
you look at the distortion of very small
discs how they
they act when you take the image and you
can control the shape here and prove
that it is crazy conformal even
globally when you take points
on the boundaries
okay so this is a very
rough idea that
how this can be
worked out when you have a pan action so
here there's a lot of analysis
and you have to understand the geometry
of the limit set and then another
compliment to go through that
but now in general of course the action
need not be
a planner so let me
ah sorry
let me
try to explain some things which can
happen
so essentially
you can have two points on the limit set
which will disconnect disconnected so
for instance
you will have some sort of
red component mr right here
you have a
mr yellow and mr white
okay and then you look at your group
action because when you take off these
three these two points it gets
disconnected
then
g need not respect the way it is mapped
so for instance if mr red
got sunburned then he might want to flip
on the other side
so he will be about something like that
mr yellow wants to get protected so
he'll go below
and mr white will remain where it was so
here you see there are two kind of
obstructions that you can get from
having a planner action
one is that you can flip the components
one by one so it will not extend to a
global map and also you can change the
secret order at the
other point
so essentially there's no hope that you
can try to figure out how to
get the right action and the right
embedding and stuff like that so you
have we have to use other tools for that
so it turns out that
these local cut points are well
understood
from the at the level of hyperbolic
geometry because it's related to the
splitting of a manifold along a
essential analysis and this has been
generalized by bowditch for word
hyperbolic groups in general
and the decomposition on the limit set
turns out to be exactly the same
and this is a way of cutting up
the dynamics on the whole limit set to
smaller pieces and then try to see what
can happen on each piece
so this is
jsj
decomposition
so what does it say
i will just give some
brief sketch
the main
feature of the the decomposition is that
your group g will act
simplistically
on a tree
t
with new edge inversions
and finite cautions
okay so the tree will be essential of
course
and
so what sort of so this just says that
you have a splitting of your group
so what are the purposes of this
splitting is first for each edge
the stabilizer of the edge is just
virtually cyclic
and its limit set
disconnects
the whole limit set
okay
so exactly like those two points for
instance this could be an edge of
a stabilizer of an edge
and the vertices are
are
three types
so one type is called
elementary meaning that it is as above
so gv is
usually cyclic
then there is one type which is called a
surface surface type which corresponds
to eye bundles or surfaces
okay so in this case
you have a canonical
cyclic order
so the group
gv is virtually free
and so the limit set is a counter set
but you have a canonical comes with a
canonical
cyclic order on the point
so which means that
it is naturally
a functioning group
and the last case
is
what burdish calls rigid case rigid
groups
meaning none of the above okay so we
understand essentially nothing
so in the context of hyperbolic three
manifolds these are these corresponds to
a cylindric part by many points
and so
here what we see is that at least when
we cut the group into pieces
we understand fairly well the elementary
piece because these are the cyclic ones
those i've already said that they look
like friction groups
and then there's the last case
of the rigid vertices
and
the key point here is that
the dynamics is so complicated then that
it cannot act in any way in the plane
once you have this embedding
okay so the key point is that
a v is a rigid vertex
then the action
of its stabilizer
on its limit set
is the restriction
oh an action
of
itself on the horse here
okay it is topological
and so then this means that i'm back to
case one when i had a planner action and
so here even though
the limit set can be totally
disconnected or
whatever the topology it is
it is always
always comes from a
global action of the group
okay so let me just give
try to explain what's going on here so
you have your limit set lambda v
and what you know
is that attached to
it there are several
you have the edges each edge of the tree
comes
defines the good points of the global
group
or the global limit set and so i
have some connected things which are
good to them like this corresponding to
edges
so here since it's not a local cut point
it means that
i have many little things going coming
out there
and so the basic idea that people do
usually in three manifolds is that they
have this manifold they pinch the curves
and then they get a geometrically finite
cleaning group and work with this and so
here we can do exactly the same so
these components can be rather wild
and
so there are
there are some sort of
okay
but they are nonetheless
connected so i could replace
each component by an arc
and then pinch the arcs and the
decomposition of the sphere using these
arcs is not very hard to prove that it
has to be
it has to be
an opposite continuous decomposition of
the sphere and then you can shrink it
little by little and you can do it at
the level of the canon group k you
started with if you want to get this
limit the
to get the pinch model of your limit set
and in this case
the topology of the limit set you obtain
is well understood it cannot the
boundary of the components cannot
separate the limit set and therefore you
have to have a planar action in this
case
once you have a plane reaction on the
quotient then you just lift it and check
that you can do it consistently to get
an action of the group globally
okay
and so then here we can think that we're
almost done
because
we have our group we cut it into
several pieces and each piece they are
virtually canyon groups
okay because since this is canyon
the color is that gv is
literally
but of course each piece is not really a
cleaning group it's just virtually a
canon group for instance the age groups
i don't know they are cyclic they're
just virtually cyclic
and so
there's one case where we can try to do
that
if the
the jsj decomposition is nice
nice in which sense
well in the sense that
go
i will be able to
so now the idea is to try to use
inductively the
clean muscle theorems to glue together
the canine groups if they are nice
so of course very hard because i don't
have any conformal structure to start
with
but actually it's exactly what thurston
did when he proved his theorem on
hyperbolization so the easiest way for
me to
do the work is try to define a three
manifold okay so now i want to find some
some properties
that i could add to the jsj the
composition to make sure that i can
build a many three manifolds to
to get a
group
to show that g will be the fundamental
group of
hyperbolic manifold and apply first one
theorem for heightened magnitudes once
so this is what i want to call
a regular
jsj decomposition
so there are essentially
two conditions that i want to ask the
first is that g is torsion-free
so in this case i will
at least be closer to a
fundamental group of a manifold
and also i won't have this problem of
having virtually cyclic edges or our
elements
and the second condition is
i had this action here i did not know
how to control the cyclic order but
since the limit set is locally connected
i know i have infinitely many components
so i would like the components to be
fixed by the action of the elementary
groups that appear under
the composition
so the action
of
elementary groups
so which are cyclic now acting
on the connected components of the
complement of the limit set
is treasure
and so
i claim that if i have this assumption
then i know how to build a manifold and
this is a
well-known procedure
so
the idea is the following
so hm you have an elementary group
i can see it as the fundamental group of
solid taurus okay and what i did not say
is that in this decomposing
decomposition of bowditch i know that
there are infinitely edges attached to
such a vertex here
and so to for each of these edges
i will consider an analysis
to define a gluing
analyst to glue it to the rest of the
to glue it
to the rest of the other pieces
now each time i see a surface
type vertex i said it corresponded to
naturally to a
complex compact friction group so these
are
which are free so it means that i have
some holes in there
so they are finitely mini
okay so what i look is i define the i
bundle
i just take the product with the
interval and then these holes
define analyze also which i will use to
glue
the piece to glue with the rest of the
pieces and then you have the rigid type
so the rigid type i don't know exactly
how they look like but
i have some boundary components
which are compact surfaces
which are
of genocide is two
and similarly each edge
because of this property
of acting trivially on the limit set i
would know that they have to be
primitive there cannot be powers of
of other electrodemic elements in the
group
and also because the action is planar i
know also that they define hormone
simple close curves which are pair
resistant up to homotopy so this defense
pairing of the
appearing of the manifold
okay so then
for each piece
i have a three manifold with analog on
them coming from the edges
and then i just glue
the
each piece along the analog
corresponding to the the action of the
of the graph here following the manual
and
follows from the
basta theory uh the topological point of
view
of scott and wall that what you get is a
manifold with fundamental group which is
like exactly g
so in this case you can apply uh first
and theorem to say that it has to be a
clanian group okay
so in this case i'm done
so of course i made the strong
assumptions to be tortion-free
and also
that the the action here was fixing
every component
so in general it's not the case well i
don't know if it's the case or not
actually there are examples may i'll
show one afterwards i guess if i have
some
time i guess i will
that this really happens even in the
torsion-free case
and so what you want is that you want to
get rid
of the elements that bugs you that bug
you for instance the ones which change
the city order here which make the
things which do
not we should not fix the component
one by one and so the
the key property there is what jeremy
can explain yesterday is the
separability of subgroups
if i know that
the stabilizer of the components here is
separable
then i can just
forget about the other elements there i
have infinitely many classes to get rid
of and i do it in a consistent way and
then i get a finite nexup group without
distance
so
what i'm saying is that
to obtain
to get a regular
jsj decomposition
you just need to get the separability
of elementary subgroups
okay and these are all quasi-convection
groups so it's exactly the property that
was mentioned yesterday is the skew
serve property
so the only way i know how to get the
kusuf property is to get a special
action on the
cat 0q complex
or virtually special
complex okay so this is due to hydrogen
device right
and now to get such an action
it follows from the work of wise that i
just need to have a quasi-convex
hierarchy
a virtual
which is the important part of this
this follows from
so what i say is that we get it almost
for free with all the work we have done
so why is it the case well first you
start with your group g
you look at the jsj decomposition
this is already a quasi-convex splitting
of your group
right
and each piece is either elementary so
it has a hierarchy
either it is
friction groups or also i know that it
has a hierarchy
or it is a conventional compact cleaning
group
and here too the work of bergeron wise
and
and
an eagle i guess
will prove that i have also a virtu
cozy context hierarchy for those
elements
so then put all together i get a global
hierarchy
for my group so i know that
the group acts virtually especially on
on the cad 0 complex so i know that my
elements are separable and hence i can
conclude that i can get a regular gsg
decomposition by taking infinite index
and so this ends the
big sketch of the of the proof right so
actually the
to prove just the rigidity the
quasi-isometric rigidity i didn't need
really to work with
with the planner actions there are
different ways to go there using the
hierarchy directly but what i don't know
how to do is to
get rid of all this part of getting the
super ability so let me just
give you an example which is due to
kapovic and kleiner
of a group where you don't have
something which is regular
so
the construction is rather simple so you
start with a torus with two holes
say that you can oops
i guess i cannot draw better than you
and so one hole i label a and the other
one b
what they do is that they glue
they wrap around twice a around b
so they identify
a square to b
so this is an hnn extension of
of the free group of rank 3
right
and what they prove is that
this cannot be the fundamental group of
a manifold but it is virtually
it is virtually uh convex or compact so
how does it go let's try to draw the
the limit set of this group so g
is
phi 1 of s
magnitude by
identifying
s squared
so i will start with a copy
of the limit set of s
so i know it is a function group
and i have two orbits of gems which come
from both holes right so one comes from
a
and the other one
sorry from b
okay so here i have two family
holes also get my and my limit set as
the complement
okay
so i know that
to each a
hole i have to attach another copy of
the limit set along which comes from the
blue hole right
so here i have something
like this
it's attached
to a blue thing and then i have also
other copies there
okay
pretty cool okay so what happens when i
make
a act
here so it fixes this component right
because it's uh
it's how i defined it but it cannot fix
that one because a does not belong to
the edge right
with which i glued it the square so it
means that this component has to be
mapped to something else
let's make something
like this where i have another blue edge
and other holes somewhere
and when i act again with a then i get a
squared and s squared is in the edge so
it has to fix that one so the dynamics
of a
it flips this component
and it does the same at every
at every hole so each time you have
a hole
an orange hole you have two blue things
which are glued together and the action
just flips things around okay so it's
very far from being regular in the sense
i've defined
and
so what is not very
difficult to prove is that this group is
torsion free because uh
if it had some
torsion it should be in the fundamental
group of by one of s which is not the
case so
and so here you need to apply this
theorem to get rid of this oh maybe i
should say what is the jsj decomposition
in this case so this is not the jsjd
composition actually
because
here what you want to do is uh
in the jsjn composition you want to have
a colored
tree and you don't want pieces vertices
of the same type to be glued together
so the the thing that
that voltage does
is to add a vertex an elementary vertex
which corresponds to the to the
stabilizer of those two points
so you have a cyclic
map gamma here
here you have pi one of s
and then you have two edges
one which will identify
a with gamma
and b with gamma squared i guess
that's it yes okay
so this is the
the graph that you obtain from
bowditch's decomposition and then
the separability what does it do for us
well it will get a
finite covering of s
so you'll get a new group
pi over s prime
and then you will get a finite family of
cyclic groups
and for each group you will have
two blue edges
attached like this
okay
and one
orange for a
and then here you have this regular
decomposition and you can make the
growing i've explained before
so
in the five minutes that i have left i
would like to say that
so just whatever first what i want us to
stress here is that going to this finest
index group
uh might be
compulsory i mean you cannot just
hope that it won't happen and that there
will be a nice action here really
there's something
going on
and also
one of my motivations to look at
this problem
is
comes from a general conjecture about
the
characterization of canyon groups
so this conjecture is the following
we assume that g
is a word hyperbolic group
and that does its boundary is planar
and then you want to conclude that
the g is virtually
so up to finite index
convex compact
channel so the red stated it contains
canon's conjecture
when you assume that the boundary
is the whole sphere
and it also contains the so-called
kapovic kleiner conjecture
when
the boundary is a serpentine carpet so
of course i did not define what is the
word hyperbolic group
but one definition that you can
take is the fact that
your group acts on a comp maturisable
compact set as a uniform convergence
action
this is exactly equivalent and the
boundary will be that compact set on
which it has this nice action
and so what this quasi-isometric
rigidity tells us is that
you start with a group so this group
carries a geometry which is given by the
caligraph
and then either it looks like
a piece of h3 and then you're okay or it
does not and then there's no hope of
getting
a conclusion so in some sense because of
mystic rigidity tells you that this
conjunction is a well-posed problem and
there's a way of trying to find a
solution
and so the techniques that i have
explained even though they are more
complicated than for the theorem that
i've proved they can be used to get
several characters characterizations of
the
convex compact learning groups
so i will end up with this
so the theorem is the following assume
that
g is a word hyperbolic
with a planar
boundary
and the following equivalent so g is a
context or compact line and group
the second which is a little more
general that what i've said is that
g embeds quasi isometrically
in h3
another condition
which is equivalent to that one is to
say that
the boundary with this conformal gauge
embeds quasi-symmetrically our question
abuse
in the riemann sphere
we have a fourth condition which is gx
on a cat 0 tube complex
and the last condition is more technical
it is either
the boundary is the whole sphere and
then you assume that the conformal
dimension the alpha's regular conformal
dimension
of the boundary
is attained
so this is work of a bank and china
or
it is a properly a proper subset of the
sphere and then you assume that the
conformal dimension
the alpha regular conformal dimension
is strictly less than two
okay
so the theorem is that
all these conditions are equivalent
and the main ingredients are the ones
that i have described for that
so here
in fact when you have this cube complex
then you have a hierarchy which comes
for free coming from the special action
so then you just split your group and
then you rebuild the manifold little by
little
these two conditions are slight
generalizations of what i've explained
when
you know actually that it comes from a
limit set or a training group
but what you can prove is that if this
happens then the boundary has come from
all dimensions strictly less than two so
you're okay
and
in this setting here the hard part is to
rebuild the remains here and then show
that you can extend the action exactly
as
what i explained
essentially is the same
okay so i guess i should stop now and i
thank you for your attention
you